Instructor: There's a
couple of other things we can do
with destructuring, and they all
are related to functions.
They're actually very handy.
Let's go through this function
really quickly. It's a convert
currency function that takes an
amount, like 100 bucks, and it's
going to return an object that
has US, pounds, Australian
dollars, and Mexican bucks,
pesos. We run it here with $
100 Canadian, and it's going to
return to me this object here.
When I console.log that object
we see that we have all these
values here. Pretty simple.
Previously, if I wanted to get
the Australian dollars I would
say .AUD, and then if I also
wanted to get the Mexican pesos
I would .MEX and I would get
those values like that. However
with destructuring, you can sort
of return multiple values from a
function. What I mean by
that is you can't really return
multiple values, but you can
return an object and destructure
the answer from that. Rather
than just console.loging hundo,
I'm going to destructure
immediately as it comes back,
and say USD, GBP, AUD, and MEX.
Now I should be able to take
these values and console.log
them individually, and you know
that we get them. If I type one
of them in here, I see them
individual, so it didn't need
that variable with all the
properties on it. I can
destructure them all into four
separate values as I want.
Another cool thing about it is
that you do not need to care
about the order in which they
come out, because it's just an
object, so I could put this in
any order that I would want and
it would still work just fine.
Especially what's cool is that
if you only need Australian and
US, you just don't need to
destructure the rest of them,
and they will never show their
face. They're simply just going
to be returned for this function
and destructured immediately.
The other two will just be
thrown out. I can console log
USD and Australian dollars here.
Cool. That's two things
there, where you can return
multiple values as well as pick
and choose the pieces that you
want returned from a function.
The other one is default named
arguments. We already went
through that last example, where
we had a function called a tip
calculator. We had the total,
and we had the tip, and we set
that to default 15 percent, and
then we had the tax, which we
set to default 013. That
works well, because we know that
the first thing is going to be
total, second thing is going to
be tip, or was it tax? I don't
even know now. Then the third
one was tip or tax. You see, I'm
already getting confuse as to
the order. Which order should I
actually put them in? I might
end up tipping too much, or
maybe not enough. There's
some things we can do to make
this order independent. The
first thing I'm going to do is
just finish off this function
here and return to total, the
tip times the total, and tax
times the total. Then I'm
going to wrap these three
arguments in curly brackets.
What that's going to do is that,
when we pass in an object it's
going to destructure them into
three variables total, tip, and
tax, so it is not like we're
going to have to say options.
total, options.tip. It's going
to destructure them into three
variables available inside of
this actual function. Then
when we call it, we simply run
tipCalc and we pass it an object
with the total value. Maybe
that's going to be $200. We pass
the tip at 02 and we pass the
tax at 013, or whatever it is.
I'm going to put that in a
variable, give this a refresh.
Now we've got $266. That's the
total. But what is really
important here is, first of all,
I can leave off things. We don't
have to pass that undefined sort
of hole-filler, if it's in the
middle. Still works just fine.
The default tax is going to kick
in, as well as, I can put them
in any order that I please.
Maybe I want to put the tip
first and the total goes second.
It still works just as we want.
We're passing in an object here,
and it's getting destructured,
as well as, if we leave the one
out from the object that we pass
in, the defaults are filling
themselves in. One last
thing is, if you ever are to
just pass in nothing...Let's say
if we put a default for the
total be 100 bucks. This is
maybe a common order and we
would want to just run tipCalc.
What happens here? We get an
error because it cannot match
against undefined or null. It's
a destructuring error, and
that's because we have passed in
none of these things. We passed
in no object for to destructure
against, so you have to give it,
itself, a default argument, so
that if the entire argument
which is one object, if no
object is passed it's going to
default just to a blank object
and all of the three are going
to be in. This is a little
bit of a funky syntax, so it
takes some times to get
comfortable with it. Maybe try
it out throughout your work day,
but it's definitely worth
getting used to, because it's
going to really help you reduce
a lot of your boilerplate code
where you're checking for
defaults.